each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
30 so high it's nice to be here I'm
going to be talking mostly about
adaptive with mixing database cracking
as we call it in the column story area
and and this is work done with people
from CWI martin kirsten Stefan monocle
and also people from HP Labs in palo
alto get graph and corona clue and this
is work in the area of how we deal with
with large datasets we're curing
techniques in databases at least they
mostly fail when you start thinking
about how I'm going to index and I'm
going to query large datasets so let's
see what we mean so self-organizing
databases is I think very intuitive term
in databases we have indices and listen
to these illnesses are being used to
fast query data but you have the very
basic problem it is when we built
indices and within this is a con we're
going to build so there's a whole
community looking into this problem what
kind of finishes we should build and
when we should build them and this is a
very bad problem essentially if you if
you had all the time in the world and
don't they you know the perfect
knowledge in the world you would say
this in this is I want I want them and
this specific time and I'm done but what
actually happens is that in database at
least we have this auto tools and
this experts in database architecture
that they do the following little trick
you get a workload and by workload will
mean a specific data set and a set of
queries and then you do this three
little steps there it's monitoring the
performance of the system other example
of this workload and trying to predict
what the what the performance of the
system would be and then seeing all
these you have all sorts of fancy
techniques so you can do the proper
physical design
basically this prepare goes there and
prepared means that this is before query
processing so you've done some
monitoring you've done some analyzing of
the of the workload and then you start
preparing and preparing means i'm going
to create listen this is now so all this
little steps there they take time and it
takes some considerable time and some
considerable resources and you can do
them very well if you if you have the
time to do them and if you have the
resources to do them but what happens if
you don't so what happens in dynamic
environments and mostly what we care
about these environments with big data
sets so what can go wrong there okay I
guess this is not really visible to all
of you so the thing is that workload the
queries they can change so it's not only
stable when you create an index equated
with a specific query in mind and it's
going to cover a set of queries at least
at the pattern of Queens but what if
this the workload changes so then this
index is not valid anymore it's not
useful actually anymore and having you
not useful index means that you spend
you spend you know storage to say to
have the index there and you also spend
resources to maintain the index under
updates so the second bullet is what
happens if the vocal cannot be predicted
this means that the workload can change
dynamically contains very often and and
yes in the past we didn't have so much
of the scenarios but nowadays we do and
you can think of the web and you can
also think in our case what we are
mostly thinking of his scientific
databases where people get lots of data
and then they just look at the data and
start thinking what kind of quiz they
should ask and then depending on the
answers they get they say ask another
query and basically the pattern in the
mindset wolves ask the answer in dick as
they take more and more answers back
from the system so there's no initial
bottom another crucial bullet is what if
there is not enough time to prepare and
this goes here so there's enough time to
do the monitoring part and basically the
preparation part
because all this they take real a lot of
time and think again the cases of huge
datasets as we have and we're going to
really have in the future in the cases
of scientific databases and I'm talking
now about terabytes very often sometimes
even birthday as you can have in I think
to 2017 it's when they new technology is
going to come for astronomers so what do
you do then in database is even the even
just loading the data into the database
it takes hours so what if a couple of
farms more we have available data
another terabyte when are we going to do
the monitoring when are you going to do
the prediction of the preparation and
you know there's no time left for the
quitting part update is also a crucial
pattern if you building this is you have
to maintain them so the data changes you
have to change the indexes that you have
in your system so they are still valid
for the quays otherwise they're not
useful so if you have indexes that are
not useful you're paying resources
maintaining and then there's the crucial
part of very large data sets so building
an index for a small data set can be
cheap can be fast you can mainly you can
probably store it in some small little
space but what if you have terabytes of
data what do you do then so if you want
you to replace the whole project and
prepare thing with an automated system
yep you just give the database you do no
work just throw it in and yeah it
figures out what indices yep auslander
so okay you know when I started this I
was a foolish bids day but the issue
here is the fact is that in this is cost
you in loading and in space so basically
we make decisions on indices based on
whether or not if we're loading into an
area and awful lot we're willing to take
the cost and analysis so you've got to
take in the loading process as well as
the reading process because otherwise
what you're going to do is is he going
to make the analysis process cheap but
you're going to considerably
the loading process exactly exactly and
and I guess this is a basic problem in
all of computer science you build a data
structure and then you can easily
distracted physically but how much time
in how much space you need to build this
data structure so and in the top of that
other than the technical part of space
and time you're showing the knowledge
that you need this data structuring the
first place so so the reason here was
you know let's just remove all these
restrictions do nothing at first because
we don't have the time and we don't have
the knowledge and let's see what we can
do so okay us this is just what what I
describe this now so as the audience
also noticed we're trying to push all
this all this notion inside the camera
itself inside the debates ken itself and
when trying to remove all this legacy of
monitoring preparation steps the human
involvement in this in this task as well
because there's a significant human
involvement in this task even if even
with our most modern technology and
nowadays and Microsoft has done a
significant part of this of this of this
work we thought of cleaning tools this
sort of thing tools they still they give
you a recommendation they don't tell you
do that they they give a recommendation
after analysis backed with database
expert the similar person and then the
database expert say they say okay this
this this and that I want oops sorry so
basically this line here is the first
idea that we started working on and in
our cage this goes in the columns or
column stores because for the last 15 or
so years which we will be column
sourcing the CWI database group with
with a monetary system and I'm going to
explain why columns has made this this
kind of work possible or a neighbor this
kind of cord so the idea is that we do
continues on the fly physical
reorganization using every
really so there's I mean if you just see
this there's probably all sorts of
things to complain about so wonderful
are physically organization it already
sounds very straight so typically in
databases you know when you get a query
it's from there only two sacred time you
just focus on the query and you do only
the access that you have to do for this
query so you cannot process equity as
fast as possible so here we come and say
now we're going to do some fiscal
organization as well so fiscal
organization is like physically we
organize the data in memory and from
disk and let's see exactly what you mean
okay now before we see that I have the
slide here with it's basically a very in
our view of what we have done the past
gears on for this specific part so we
have a couple of techniques the base
cracking and octave merging and nowadays
not all the adaptive indexing and so
essentially we started building a new
database colonel from from bottom up and
I started working on from on the left
part you see so we started with very
basic operators like selections in
databases then we did updates of the
construction which if I have done I will
talk about it's a very crucial problem
in column stores so we do all sorts of
work and our goal is to in the end
develop a full-scale database journal
that you know across all all the debate
operators has this notion of
self-organizing to the waves at this
point as we speak our prototype is
published with with milady be so you can
download it and played it you got and it
does support it does work for for for
these three things here so you can you
can you know you can type quiz
immediately and then you get all these
ideas that I'm going to talk about and
they just work so this is this is mostly
the outline of this talk I'm going to
start with talking a bit about data
access and roses and column stores and
then the basics of database cry
King and if there is time I'm going to
go into the sideways cracking process at
risk rating which are some more advanced
techniques on how we do good approach
sink okay so I don't spend like three or
four slides on column cells versus
rosters so the well you know the way we
stop data defines the way we can access
it so when we every time we write an
operator in databases or any kind of
algorithm really the way the way that I
start on this going memory or in the
caches it defines the steps that we do
and our little body scanners are built
this way nowadays and nowadays we have
this this nice buzz words that people
are talking about roasters and column
stores and lately also hybrids and you
know you keep hearing about about this
kind of buzz words from almost everybody
and this is us and this is also a
spin-off of milady be a very recent
spin-off of madiba which we sold to
increase which also like three weeks ago
with top 3 t PCH benchmark results which
is one of the most big to be a big
benchmarks in databases but but the main
part is that you can you keep hearing
that everybody is going to is trying to
do something with with column source
with rollers and mainly with hybrids
nowadays because the in the end there is
no there's no truth for already rows or
columns source and the truth is
somewhere in the middle and people are
really looking into hybrid stores and
hybrid execution models so let's see
let's some of the basic differences so
you're also you typically store data in
rows and and you can think of this as
being the disk so you have lots of froze
when you have columns so in its role you
have the attributes and then when you
have a query quit is you know this is
this is let's say this is a relational
table the police they don't
it's square just refreshed with a part
of these attributes of the table so what
you mostly do is that you going in this
can be feds this file and basically
because of the weight stored because
it's toward one row after the other you
have to fit everything so when you say
it's stored in rows i think you mean
that the successive items of a world of
physically adjacent to it yes that's
what I'm yes exactly okay where you
stored it in I mean that same picture
would do for storage and colorless
wouldn't it if you're strong it in
columns then the physical then the items
of a column would be physically adjacent
yes exactly yes okay okay so and this is
why you have to bring the whole string
together in what too much so if we do
the same exactly the same example in the
column storm so this is our columns and
this is exactly this is physically
adjacent values then again send query
would come and then we would have to
just bring the parts that we really
interested on because we can just fight
it independently it's an issue that if a
column contains say five bit values
mm-hmm then you could cut it if you give
you add a column all of five big bodies
you have happened very tightly exactly
was in rows that would be more awkward
somehow because they need of a 5-bit
value in a separate valium getting mouth
will be much harder exactly exactly so
this could be you know this could be 16
bytes this could be two bites it's run
by this would be you know it's it's and
there are okay typically in Roasters you
have what we call invariably length
feeds variable-length things because you
know you have one attribute after the
other or fits tub so the first a bit
could be sixteen bytes the second could
be two bites but then in the you know in
the next stop with the first attribute i
could have a different value but still
use you spent you might spend 16 by
store it in column source you can do
basically what i'm trying to say is that
you can do basically better compression
because here
we just have you know this is physically
adjacent and we just have the values for
this specific for this specific
attribute which means that probably the
the value distribution is quite similar
we can we can probably do but the rent
or run-length encoding this is it's
basically the same type so this this is
only in the church and this is only
thing so this can be on the float and we
can do all sorts of tricks to nicely
packet together and in column stores
it's a very big deal that these are
fixed length so it's column is of when
it can work with variable length but
every implementation uses fixed length
and the idea is that when you scan these
columns here the if they're fixed length
they are arrays so let's say a single
selection over here it's just you know
you just get a pointer and you say I see
this value increase this pointer one
position and it's in deter so you don't
have doing it you just increase four
bytes let's say you're eight bytes and
then you're done so you can write
operators in the matter of two or three
lines of code very efficient with very
nice access buttons with very nice
temporal locality for your dating and
and this is this is one of the really
main differences between columns and
rows but it's it's yeah it's mostly
adapting to new hardware and Deitrick
that so one here you you know you
noticed another queries interested in
two columns and we just brought one here
so we have the required flexibility I
just brought one column here and I can
process it and then only then I can
bring the next one so you can also have
you know you can always buy having
columns independent independent from
each other you can always bring the part
that you go on drop it then bring the
next one and go on you don't have to
bring so it's not only that you bring
only the columns that you need you can
break independently one column after the
other and be
even more efficient in terms of memory
requirements of your system okay that's
only true if the operation never needs
both column at the same time I mean I'm
so imagine you were to add the columns
then you can't just process them in one
go you can Wow okay if you keep the
curative thumb but so yeah this this is
this is a big discussion so the the
monetary system that i mentioned what we
do is that we bring one call them at a
time we run a complete operator over
this column so in databases shop you
know you have operators like i select
something and then i do an aggregation
let's say okay so we can do first the
complete selection and not only then we
can do the aggregation this means that
let's say we do a selection here and
aggregation here we can first bring this
column scan it completely do this
election and well and then for the for
the take the intermediate result and run
the complete aggregation this is
completely different from what is being
done now in gross toes in typical
systems and okay this doesn't have to do
with rows and columns just past
technology and new technology basically
we're in typical traditional roles you
do you take one couple at a time and you
pass it through the complete operator
three so the selections aggregations
Jones what you have and then you take
the next step and you passed again
through the complete thing where where
are the intermediate results of each
single rushing in this way so this curve
so in a typical roaster you you know the
demitted results are very small rely in
the in columns one you have to
materialize you have to materialize them
so then you have the memory over here
because you have to materialize in the
middle results which is why so in the in
the in the muleta be carolyn we actually
materialized everything so one operator
will materialize the complete limited
result and then go to the next one in
the vector wise technology is basically
you're trying to find some intermediate
solution so you take you know it instead
of taking one couple at a time like you
doing roasters or you can stay
making the complete column like we're
doing money to be in vector wise we take
a bath of a batch of its column so we'll
take you know a part of this column and
then go to the next door yeah it's
basically you know this piece is they
fit in the glasses and you can actually
amortize the faction causative do
because every time you call an operator
become a function call and endorses you
do a function called per couple
basically / operator which is very
expensive in our case from where they be
we do basically one function call /
operator which is extremely expensive
but then you get laid immediate results
materialization problem so vector wise
finds some some of them we did solution
but I guess I think the next two slides
probably is the discussion that we just
it now so you know is it is it that
column stores that are good because you
you can access data better on this and
the answer is no so as I said in in
typical system to process one row at a
time and this is it has a very high
overhead because you have to cut the
compute a blues you know from disk
memory in cassis instance registers and
you have the the functional overhead of
of every predator has to say give me the
next stop give me the next stop give me
the next up all the time and of course
but what the main thing is here you you
have tons of cash misses just because
you carry everything together although
you don't need it but definitely it's
low on memory needs because don't have
any immediate results basic and and
actually if you go back like 40 years or
so into database technology you would
see that some of the early systems
actually failed because they had the
strategy of meticulous materializing
intermediate results so this was this
was a good idea in the past but it's
probably not the best idea nowadays so
in roasters ah let's maybe even use the
world traditional
let's processing of one column at the
time and in the block model as I said
one operator at a time ok so the volcano
volcano is this is the terminology in
databases for for this pipeline model so
you take one tablet you pass it through
all the operators and then you take the
next one and you pass each other
critters and so on start slots the
traditional volcano model so with with
with one column at a time you can you
can carry in your memory hierarchy only
what you need and so this you can think
about it I have a selection I go to disk
I fetch this call may I movie to memory
to the cache to the CPU and then when I
risk the CPU there's only the values
that I need there's nothing else it's
only values afraid the vector based
operators is the example I try to keep
it forward where you do basically
array-based operators which is very
efficient implementation and I'm gonna
so very small example later and then
this may be another thing is the
optimization decisions which is is it
it's quite a nice one so when you think
of it as well as when you process one
row at a time and you move it through
the operators typically you know the
operators are are are initially logical
operators but you also have to decide
the actual algorithm for its operator so
say when you do a selection you might
choose to scan the data you might just
build the hash table and then probably
hash table you might just to sort the
data in the binary search might just
tons of options when you do its own you
might just do a hot zone or do a sort my
design so typically you have the the
optimizer when you get the query at the
first place in in rosters and decides
the query plan and the sides also the
fiscal operators so it says you can do
this operator you can I use this
algorithm and then this other operator
this algo and so on but choosing the
algorithms it's obviously very sensitive
task and depends a lot on
on the data distribution and depends a
lot on the one Operator depends on the
answers of the previous operator so in
in column source when we do the column
of the time processing once quick thing
is one operator we have the complete
results set and then we can confidently
say that for the next operator we know
because we know the cardinality we have
seen the data we know we want to use
this kind of physical operator so you
can you can delay the civilization
decisions and put them and take them at
runtime and then take more informed
decisions but we have to do it in the
method materialization as we've said and
another crucial problem is double the
construction and this is and this is
actually one of the main problems in
column stores because you you have one
column at a time and then you have to
you have to combine columns because quiz
rarely use one column they use two three
you know you need is a number of columns
then if you have to combine the data
across multiple columns and this is the
problem of trouble with construction and
the techniques that i'm going to show
also help significantly in basically
optimizing and even eliminating this
problem in column search so I said the
tablet reconstruction problem is is that
is the one of basically stating doubles
together and one could think that okay
I'm how I could do a column store I put
stored data per column on disk and then
when queries arrived I'm going to fetch
these columns I'm going to make them
tuples so I do get the IL cost they are
the io benefits I just fits only this
top is that they need and I fetch them
all together at the first place and then
I assist them in the tabs and then I can
you know using my typical roast or query
processing and I don't have to change my
system so i do get all the almost of all
the io benefits and i can still use my
past colonel so now if you know if you
know that you only need some of the
columns if you needed all other columns
then you get no benefit at all right
no it depends on it bet it depends on
the query it depends on the query when
you give an example in which you make
your difference you can query what you
need all the columns and yet it would be
better to load all the columns and glue
them into tuples than to just do user
versatile ah no I can give an example
that this would be better I can give an
example where this would be better right
they always been in the top on so the
top one looks as if it degenerates to a
roast or yes yes you need all that you
yeah so the top one is is like a very
fast way to bring the columns or let's
say because you can keep your query
processing colonel intact basically and
you just need an intermediate step that
says go to my columns of storage and
bring me things and then make them
immediately cut apples so you can use my
past Kermit okay and that would be that
would perform very similarly to a
standard versatile that would perform in
terms of execution similarly start to a
standard roaster and you would get some
of the benefits of fetching data
basically more efficiently because you
won't have to load the full columns the
whole columns now it's it let's say you
have ten columns and acquitting it's
just two of them so I say if you need
all the columns it would be the same if
you don't constitute the same it will be
slower actually because you have to do
this little boy ok but so what so what
it happens in column sources that we use
this late ability construction which
basically means that you don't only
change the storage you also change the
execution you have to write a new kernel
user code to have a column store and
these are all the tricks that and there
are many more all the things we have
been struggling so far the ejector like
brushing that the fact that you have the
CPU and the cast optimized because you
just bring the data that you need into
your registers and everything you can
have more efficient lector wise coding
and you do the bulk processing as
opposed to the volcano and depending on
the query even if you need all that also
even if you need all the columns and if
you are going to eventually load all the
column this can still be orders of
magnitude faster than a typical roster
because of all the better adapt into
hardware
so let's let's now you know let's see
how the columns would look like so let's
say these are the columns a b c and d
and this I don't know you like sort of
reddish color is the these the actual
values of the columns of the other
buttes and the great part is is the
positions and you can think of the
positions we use them as identifies row
identifies and and in memory and disk
these are just erase this great part
does not exist it's just it's just
implicit knowledge you know we just know
this is the first the second the third
and so on so we don't we don't actually
materialize this thing we just have the
array of the of the red part missing
data is explicitly identified the
maggots right sorry missing values are
explicitly identified missing funds what
the heck trees i believe the third row
of calling the nose oh yeah it will be
you know you would have a specific value
for not you know just is this storage
only the very beginning where your data
list because in the pipeline you might
have filtered some columns so sure yes
of course of course we're gonna say it
an exact example of personal pretty so
it's so here columns are aligned this
means that I don't yet so handsome so
let's say what would beat Apple five in
a row stir storage is the same as now
going up in the fifth position of every
column and just sing the value so for
four columns see the value that
represents the the fifth tablet c5 and
and you know this you know I just draw
them here just for convenience you know
they look the same but as we talked
before it might be different this might
be you know sixteen bytes it might be
four byte and so on so if this is an
integer of 4 bytes if i want to go to
the fifth position i just do you know
four times five and a jump here this is
contiguous in memory disk
so it's it's always if you see a column
store code it's always playing with with
these positions in the arrays to move
across the arrays so let's let's do now
let them know a single query so this is
sequel query we want to select the
average of column C given that we do a
selection or night Ricketts be and a so
we have some very simple filtering
predicates on DNA and whatever qualifies
we want to do an average on column C so
lets you know we start with the first
select operator let's select over a and
this one will just scan the column and
create intermediate results and these
are the robot needa fires that qualify
the selection and as we're discussing
before this is this is all it is this is
just this is the code of the of the of
the operator just just simply scanning
the column and you can see how this is
extremely efficient because you just
have this column it's contiguous it's
physically contiguous and this is
exactly as it is and the results here
now we have to materialise its result
and they just represent these positions
so so now after we did this operation we
know exactly the the row and the device
of the tops of qualified from our first
election and now we have to do this type
of the construction action and this is
this is now an overhead compared to
typical roadster because what you have
to do now is you could say even what
qualified from from one column you have
to go and fetch the the qualifying
values from the other column in this
case we have to go into column B and we
do the sergeant so again this is this is
very fitting so as I said this is again
continuing memory we just go to the
first position to the third position to
the fifth position and so on and again
this cure
depends on the data type here and we
know the data type so we can just move
very fast on the column you said you
have to materialize the intermediate
result yes but do you really couldn't
these two learners co routines the first
one produces one say mm-hmm or and then
three and then the second one can you
can you can use those values as you know
what you could stream the the result the
intermediate result rather than
materializing yes so so so this is if
you do it one top a little time so you
could you know you could take the first
value and say it qualifies no okay you
can take them the Second World qualifies
yes ok go fetch the b-value discuss of
this has a very high functional over
here because you have to do all the
function calls of doing these
intermediate steps so we found out that
it's very fitting to do it one column at
the time the one function call do the
complete operation and then materialize
and immediate result of course then we
found out again that okay maybe this is
a complete overkill and there's
something in the middle and this is the
the vector wise code line that I talked
before which essentially takes it will
take ok how it will say okay tip leads
it's l2 cache we say how many values fit
here this month I'll take this much and
then pipeline the operations over there
so you take the first three values let's
say and you do you run all the operators
that i'm going to show you now and then
you take the next three and so on so you
try to amortize and the balance the
functional cost with the the cost of me
realize intermediate results
so now now we just this tablet
construction so we we we found the B
values that qualify given the selection
on column a and now we have to do this
election on column B and you know
because because we took this Basin
column may than this this is also would
be that it will give us also the
addition on both attributes so now we do
again the selection and then we say okay
only a topless one and five qualify but
now we have to do also the aggregation
one column C so again I'm have the
double bigger selection so again we go
over the complete column of C and we
face the values and now we're there and
now we can run the aggregation again all
these operations are like array
operations so even the aggregation you
can work in a very cost-conscious way
over it but let's see let's let's talk a
bit more about top of the construction
so you see this this type of the
construction thing it happens very often
essentially you have to do it forever
you attribute that you have in India
query plan it's very crucial that you
keep your columns online so you see all
these actions here you have this error
that one five one three five six and so
on so you produce this position such as
she go through the column so this is
always ordered at least in this example
here so so then you can do nice
sequential axis over over your columns
and doing sequential accesses is crucial
for performance and also you do position
look up so you don't have to actually
you know search where it's double one
it's just as I said you take the number
one you multiply with with the width of
the column which is with this based on
the type and you're there so this can be
very efficient but in many cases as a as
we've seen here it might actually be
spread over the whole column and then
because typically you even in memory
than disk and then classes you either
but we do
Bart's access basically bring caste
lines or disclose etc you here in this
case for example you will still end up
loading the complete big column into the
Casas just do the tablet massage yes so
it's sequential measures that that's the
reason going to Simon's question why you
don't want to do streaming where why
don't want to kind of like do this in
parallel it might seem like it faster it
will actually ruin the sequential you
really have to go to the disc right now
the sequential don't have to do with the
parallel processing this equation does
have to do with just being efficient
when you access data you will still do
it the same way if you would do it in a
parallel way how I mean if these two
columns in your sword in the same days
you start to do the query your circle
select things were a smaller than if you
want let's say you've got their first
result and now you're going to attempt
to finally call me me but there are
certain the same disk and that this
really has only one head so you bet
you're better off reading fully a and
then going and reading fully be so how
you actually would do it is that you'd
you would store let's say you know the
hundred apples 400 values from a hundred
values from B and so on so so
essentially you know a would you to be
logically column but in practice it will
be you know physically it will be 10
columns or thousand columns and each one
would contain hundred or a thousand
values also is not physically stored
contiguously yes in this case it would
not be subtle continuously and then you
could just load the first the first you
know the first column of a and then all
the qualifier values would represent
would be representin the first column of
B and so on and this way you can
pipeline efficiently wait if this dog is
rose and they're all contiguous anyway I
mean you assume and everything got the
same number of yeah 146 and the roll so
you could actually just have one row
which is ABC you got one overhead which
is the position you pull them all in
them and their contiguous on this so
that's ball faster than having
columns which it distributes is rounded
this yep it's faster in this case it's
faster so if we so let's say you have a
table with thousand attributes okay and
let's say you do a query with that lack
of the hill that we only need three
other views yeah that's a dinghy what
you're saying is the fact is is that it
the number of columns in long table and
majority of them and I be used then
column ways becomes more efficient yep
where is it but so if if you use most of
the columns in a table that roadway
becomes more g unit so it could be so
there's because the continuously space I
can construct and we have constructed so
many examples where it also would be
better so I'm not I'm not saying that
columns are better okay i just i said
before that hybrids are better that's
clear so you could construct so many
examples where a roast or implement this
would be better and in fact in the in
hybrid architecture that we're trying to
build right now what we do in many cases
is that we do typically our selections
and in a column in a column way in a
columnar way and then at some point we
reverse on the fly we reverse our
intermediate result so we take all these
intermediates we do the top of the
constructions and we revert them into
into tablets and then we go ahead and do
aggregations on the flat because it's
it's it's simply faster to do to do this
operations in a corner way but then it's
also it's also a matter of how the air
cannon looks like because then you're
sewing dynamic code to do this it's it's
not simple but but it's true that hybrid
storage and habit execution is is better
so what the example that I'm trying to
demonstrate here is you know they the
extreme columnstore exam we just give
you the feeling of of how it looks like
five more minutes
ok so then what I'm gonna do is that I'm
gonna give the the bags the basic
example of the adaptive of the adaptive
indexes on the adaptive storage so okay
so we did all this elections before and
you know we still have to scan all the
data so how you doing this is in a min
column so how do you the fish efficient
indexes you could build you could you
could start taking the columns and you
know you can sort them that's that's one
way of building indexes in the console
and then you can do binary schedule you
can build and three of record so in our
in our adaptive indexing motivation that
I showed you earlier we said that we
don't want to do anything upfront
because we don't know we don't know in
which widths columns the quiz will use
and we don't know how efficient our
index would be so we might need one
query took we sorta might mean this is
for part of the column and for the whole
problem so what we do and I'm going to
give it to us an example basically it's
query in the by the can you list it as
an advice of how the data should be
stored so let's let's let's see here
lets you have this election here and
this in databases this is just one one
Operator just a select operator to do
this filtering in the well close so what
we do is that we take this column and
now the operator itself will physically
reorganize the column so you see here
the predicates are between 10 and 14 so
what we do is that we we take all the
values that are smaller than 10 and we
move it move them to the first part of
the column and then we take all the
values that are actually willing the
result and we move them in the middle
and then all the values the bigger than
the result so now this is this in this
area here which is again a contiguous
area we have all the all the tabs that
qualify for the Select operator okay and
now you notice that we actually the
Select operator doesn't have to
Oh materializes result because it can
just say it's there it's a view because
it's just you could dig use a vague
memory and the top of that and the
crucial part is that we just gained some
knowledge of how the data is stored
right because we know this is sort of
clustering here do you similarly we
organized the other columns yeah that's
we're not going to get to that but yes
you do yes yes but not not not now not
not now now for this query would just
touch this call okay when other queries
comes that that they need they need you
know they are on the same table and they
need this column and some other column
possibly then we have to talk then we do
what we do is that we transfer this
fiscal every organization would transfer
it to the other column as well in such a
way that we can always do sequential
axis unfortunately I'm not going to get
up to this point but let's go through
this and we can talk later let's go
through the basic stuff and as I said
this is this is happening within the
Select operator so this is not enough
time I think this is this is how the
camera works and then we get another
query and now we can we can use this
clustering information and this query
now says okay everything between 7 and
16 and the camera keeps working this way
so we go into this column and you say
okay we knew now everything smaller than
10 so the seven-part folds in this area
and we're going to break this piece
again in two pieces the one step smaller
than 7 and once at the bigger than 7 now
for the next part it's it's always in
the result so there's no reason to touch
it and now this we get the benefit
because we don't touch data and again
similarly we split the next part based
on the next predicate and again what we
do is that we collect all the results
neck in a contiguous area and of course
we gained even more knowledge we can
which we can use in future waves so in
some ways you can think of this as
wasn't incremental incrementally sorting
the the column because this are ordered
but inside the space there's no order
and but but it is completely reacting to
the to the query workload so you really
focus in the value rains and the parts
of the columns are your queries are
interesting about how you connect it up
to the other columns if it was a column
B and C and D then you should have
scrambled column a so how do you
reconnect it with the original ah not
yet scrambled are we need our school
pairs the index and the value so so what
do you do is that in 15 mins so what do
you do is that you bet you again with
changed so this was the second iteration
of the scandal to building and this is
the sideways crack in part that you saw
in the outline sideways in the sense
that you move sideways in the columns
this organizational information so what
we do is that we we take then pairs of
columns and then we always have a
leading column so let's say it would be
a b2b a pair and AC it would be another
pair and they did would be another pal
and then we'll use work in pairs of
columns so if you'd end its and it's set
of pairs is is always having a leading
column that defines the organization ok
so then all this all these parts of
columns will be reorganized based on all
the selections of attribute a and then
inside you do further filtering and
again across all the spares you
adaptively move the organization part
sold you a query comes on it be you take
the pair of a B you do some
reorganization then a query comes from
AC and then you synchronize synchronize
this this column's physically so they
are at the tops are aligned and as long
as the tubs are lined you can give back
correct results and then you move on
doing organization so ok that was one
minute but it's a bit more complicated
with them we can discuss with you
thank you so this is a very simple
example song some basic performance or I
this looks so this is you know having a
10 million column of integers and doing
100k completely random selections random
in the sense that everything is
completely random so the the selectivity
of the quiz is random and also the the
value ranges were that you ask in the
quiz everything is completely random so
no index has been built up front and the
the green line here the green give
represents the standard scan
functionality mccombs oh so you're with
scan the data and the red curve here
represents the the cracking stuff but I
have been talking about and this is you
see that it the more queries you answer
this is the quiz and this is the
response time the more quiz you answer
the better the performance becomes and
this is the reason the reason is that it
adds less and less data because of the
of the classroom you ask a lot of
queries then your bin size the size of
your little gray pulses is going to
generate 21 yes now finding the right
bin is solving the original query so so
so we don't let this happen because
there's this there's a couple of reasons
first when you get when you want the
pieces become really small that they fit
in the cars then we just saw because
it's do a quick salt in the cast and
then you're done the other problem is
that the if you if you if you if you
start having a tree because we built it
three to maintain the index if you start
building a tree over its specific bin
that you have and it's been it's just
sighs one then simply the cost of
searching the tree to go there it's it
explodes okay so but then again but then
there's and then there's other problems
so the more pieces you have the more of
the species you have this means that the
more knowledge you have the more class
than you have on your columns right
which becomes a problem during updates
because I said we also have continues
we're going to have everything to dig
you see memory so the more pieces we
have the more we have to shift around
during updates and then also during
updates with drop pieces and solvents
this maybe I'll just thinking credible
the spot here like if I was oracle com
okay why not go for something much
simpler given the data is already
replicated multiple times right one can
if this is a very nice question so why
don't that just one of the coffee's this
sort as well store and the other coffee
start as a column start so if certain
parts of the workloads 1 2 x's they're
all stores park you just you know me so
yeah that's that that's what people
started doing so this was this was
actually a paper from Wisconsin I don't
know 15 years ago on fractal middle
shitless code so so yeah this is one
solution but again this is on the
storage part right you're showing in the
cannon so you need two different cannons
could do this column and row storm so
you in a way those kernels are written
right oh I'm not sure so you need a
completely different company you cannot
reuse anything that you have in a row so
you have to do a completely different
implementation and there was a guy in
MIT that did exactly a PhD just on that
he said can we take a roaster and make
it a column store just by you know
storing data differently moving them in
and the answer is no it's not efficient
it's sorry but you are saying Oracle has
it isn't call them sorry implementation
or sequel server in fact I know sequel
server has a column story I know the
terminal because it comes from right in
this way so you take one of the pieces
of sequel server and you're running on
server a you take another instance and
your answer from be oh that's perfect
yeah that's with some middleware you
mean ah I do appreciate a good meal
working yeah yeah sure sure sure but the
again again then so that's one great
solution but then again you're not
optimal and okay we can discuss if you
want to go up to Mabel sure sure so it's
very simple but at least what what I see
that people in industry are doing and is
that they're trying to move into hybrids
so they're trying to move into both into
storage and execution and Ohio
because it it helps with compression it
tells you thick skin
some performance so so I guess this is
one fair solution that you can do as
your first version but you're not going
to stick to that I'm sure okay last
slide maybe if you're wondering how this
compares to a normal index if you would
be the index up front and then just you
know you do very first place that take
microseconds so this is this is the same
experiment in all graphs this is this is
just the first and quiz the first
hundred quid and this is the complete
picture and this green curve here is
what the the normal index looks like and
this is cumulative cost so this is
adding the you know the first the second
and third and so on so you see that even
after 10,000 queries building the
complete index has not amortized the
cost over doing cracking so that's us as
an indicative you know the way we think
we don't want to spend a huge cross from
the beginning and still be very fast
here because this is you see how this
comes down this is this is answering
questions microsecond but be driven
after 10,000 quiz he hasn't amortized
this blue this blue curve here is is yet
another technique that we have in an
algorithmic wafer w enix you this am
adaptive imagine it's being called which
you see you have sort of an intermediate
cost here but then it has faster quiz
and then cracking because it it comes
faster but and the whole research here
that we do is we're trying to balance
the how much effort we put a front with
how much comets and much faster we
can convert into the what would be the
optimal performance of an offer full
index and I leave it closing with this
and if I think the sort of some kind of
data flow diagram with tuples or things
flowing through operators then I I think
what you're saying is that the operators
near the leaves they can as it were
reach back and reorganize the data
they're getting for exactly the
operators deeper in the tree they can't
really reach back and or do that reach
back and reorganize
the data sort of into somehow pushing
back through the previous guys right it
was it just the leaf ones that do this
reorganization thing ok so the so
there's the monsters there's just the
live ones let's see that's one answer
but then the second answer is that you
remember I was talking about
materializes materializing this
intermediates so this can be an overhead
of course but it's also an opportunity
because you can not realize this in
immediate and then you can keep them so
you can remember them in the future so
you're going to reuse them I say so you
can reorganize them and you can keep
them for so quick so you can play
the same game on the intermediate or
cashed in to meet you yeah yeah
you